[Music]
hello everyone
so uh in the previous part of the
lecture now we had been discussing about
the concept of contraction and
near the end of the lecture
i had briefly mentioned how this
particular instance of contraction
between a second order tensor and a
vector can be represented
in a shortened matrix representation in
this form furthermore
in compact notation in this one and the
alternative contraction
uh in this particular form of the index
notation
the equivalent matrix representation was
this involving the transpose
and it was here in written in compact
notation
so that was discussed in very brief and
i had mentioned in passing
that there would be uh so i would be
discussing a systematic way
of obtaining these equivalent
representations
uh and in this part of the lecture we
are going to do that
now uh before we can actually launch
into that systematic way
we have to first go through a a very
short
fundamental discussion about uh the
the outer product or the dynamic product
of two unit vectors
so what we'll do is we'll consider
first of all this unit vector
e one hat
with this okay so maybe
uh it's better if i choose to do it with
itself
so e 1 divided product with e 1 itself
now uh as we had
as we had seen earlier
this diadic product in equivalent matrix
representation
it would be e1 at
multiplied with e1 hat
transpose okay now
what that would mean is so you know the
matrix representation of the e1 hat
is nothing but in the matrix form this
is nothing but 1
0 0
similarly this one will be 1 0 0 but
written as a
row so let me just quickly tell you what
is going on here
so you see
suppose we are we are back in our very
familiar x y z coordinate system
so in that x y z coordinate system our
unit vectors
are i hat j hat and k hat
okay now if you want to represent
so let me just quickly uh write write
this down in the rough column here
so suppose we are writing this i
hat okay so
if i want to write the components
of this i hat that are present along the
different coordinate
axis what are the values so along the x
axis
that is along the direction of i hat it
is
1 okay along the direction of j
hat it is 0 and along the direction of k
hat it is 0 so that is what is
represented here
by the 1 0 0 similarly if i had
the j hat that is the unit vector along
the j direction
along the y direction the scalar
components of that unit vector
of the unit vector would be 0
along the x direction 1 along the y
direction
because the entire unit vector is lying
along the unit along the y direction
and along the k direction it will be 0
and similarly for k hat
it would be 0 0 1 and
exactly the same thing is going on here
so for the unit vector
along the x 1 direction i have 1 0
0 and here also for the e 1 i have the 1
0 0
but this transpose is making it like a
like a row
okay so uh if i
if i actually carry out the matrix
multiplication
what i will obtain here is simply 1
0 uh
it will be zero zero
zero and zero zero zero
so you see how this has shaped up only
the element sitting in the first row and
the first
column that has the one value
similarly if you consider the
e1 diadic product with e2
then what is it going to be we have to
write it like
so the equivalent matrix representation
is e 1 hat
multiplied with e 2 hat but that comes
with a transpose
and that is equal to as before 1 0
0 but now
we have 0 1 0
so if we actually carry out this matrix
multiplication what we will obtain
is 0
1 0
0 0 0
0 0 0 that's it
okay and you can actually quickly see
what is going on here
so when you have the one and the one
present
ultimately what is happening is that in
the first row and the
first column only the one value is
appearing
similarly when you have the one and the
two here
so it is like the first row and the
second column
that is where the one is going to appear
the first row and the second column
that is where the one is going to appear
similarly if you had taken
e2 direct product with one then the one
would have appeared here
okay similarly for other combinations so
you remember this
now uh using uh
these kinds of dyadic products between
the unit vectors uh we will be able to
write
the uh the tensors of various orders
in a in a more explicit fashion in the
in the component wise notation so what
we want to do here
is quickly go back and
look at the the component-wise notation
that we had written for the vector here
we want to write something similar
for tensors of higher order so
what we are going to do here is
for a tensor of order 2
we are going to write this as e i j
e i d product
with e j
now uh what this e i diatic product with
e j means is that
if you if you expand this out with the
various combinations of i
and j and then you appropriately
you take this put this i and j here also
so what i mean to say is that if you
actually expand it out like this
that i equal to 1 j equal to 1
so that you have
this thing plus t
1 2 e 1
e 2 plus
e 1 3 e 1
i d product with e 3 and so on and so
forth
all the 9 possible combinations until
you
end up with the
c2 e3 dieting product with
e2 plus e3
e3 product
e3 dieting product with e3 so if you
when you write down all these nine
things
and you expand all of these things in
matrix representation
uh ultimately what you are going to
arrive at
is the equivalent matrix representation
of the second order tensor in this
particular form
that is what i mean now
let me just complete this thing
so this is the equivalent matrix
representation obtained in a systematic
fashion
by expanding out like this okay
so uh how can we use this so that is
that is the question that we want to
answer
is that how can we use this kind of an
explicit component-wise notation
to obtain a systematic procedure
to write out these kinds of things
in terms of the index notation that we
have done
instead of going through all these steps
in between
so let's take up the case of
the the second second order ten set
e are dotted with
the first order tensor b
now in component notation
what this will be is
e i j e i
did product with e j
this entire thing dotted with
v k e k
k hat okay now
as i had mentioned in one of the
previous parts of the lecture
that here this t i j by itself and this
v k by itself
they are like the scalar components by
themselves okay
and all the strength of the vector or
the tens and notations
they are carried by these various
operations between the
the unit vectors so we can take this
t i j v k to one side
and write out the unit vectors
sequentially like this as they appear
okay we just write them out in sequence
now
among these among these things that are
present
you note you identify that this e j
dotted with e k that is nothing but the
chronicle delta
j k okay so
this is v k the e i
remains as it is but the e j
dotted with k that becomes delta j
k
now some of you may be wondering that
what happened
to this product well you see
this diet product is basically to
explicitly
denote that the fact that we are having
uh this particular combination as a if
you just look at this thing
this is like a uh like a
second order tensor the e i and the ej
but there is nothing really uh i mean
sacrosanct
about uh or uh
or i should say that uh writing it
writing it in this
diet product form here and this dot
product form
it should not give you the impression
that this is perhaps more important than
this
okay so
we should not fall under any sort of
wrong impression uh
in that way so what is basically
happening here
is that there is very much a contraction
going on here
so this e j dot k
but in terms of the symbolic notation
that gives us
this delta j k and the actual
uh contraction business that is achieved
finally by the substitution of this
chronicle delta what is whatever is
common here
so again we have two choices this j can
be
this j here the the t i j this j here
can be replaced by
k or you can consider this delta j k
with the v k
so that this k gets replaced by the j so
overall what we can have is either
t i a
v k and the e i
present or
we can have t i j
v j with the e i very much present
okay so please do not get confused by
the presence of this
dyadic product okay
now if you look back at uh at the
previous parts of the lecture
you will see that whatever we have
written here for this t dot v
here you see the t dot v this was the t
i k v k and we had to go through this
long drawn procedure to
obtain the equivalence between this
index notation and this
compact notation and here
through the operations between the unit
vectors
we have managed to obtain that without
going through
uh through that that long drawn matrix
representation
and see that ultimately whatever you are
obtaining here
the explicit presence of one unit vector
represents
that this entity itself is
a vector quantity or a tensor of order
one
which is as it should be as we have
already seen
now next uh suppose we consider the t
transpose uh dotted with v
so we want to explore what happens to
this
to this alternative
okay so
so let's go to the next stage
and consider that
so what we have is so in the previous
slide we had
e dot v now we are going to consider the
second order tensor t the transpose of
that
dotted with v so basically the
contraction going on here
now here in the previous page
you note that the t without the
transpose
it was t i j e i i d product with j
but when we have the transpose we can
still write it like t i j
but the fact that we are carrying out
the transpose means
that this particular thing has to be
reversed so instead of the e
i a diatic product with j we have to
write this
as the e j daddy product with i and
if you go back a few pages we have
already discussed
uh this particular thing here
so you see that this b dynamic product
with a that was actually the
a dynamic product with b transpose okay
so that is the fact that we are going to
use
right now okay so
the t i j remains as it is
and the transpose
the fact that we are writing the
transpose is implemented
in this fashion by reversing the orders
of the
order in which the unit vectors are
written and this entire thing is dotted
with the pk
with the ek hat now as before we take
first of all
the tij dk to one side
write out so once you have the first
line ready the rest of it is following
in a very algorithmic fashion
so this is dotted with
k we don't worry about the presence of
this dyadic product symbol
and realize that e i dotted with k is
nothing but the delta i k
so this is t i j v k
e j remains as it is and this is delta i
k
and now as before we are going to
utilize the substitution power of the
chronicle delta alternatively first with
this one and then with this one to get
equivalent expressions
so if you consider the tij with the
delta ik what we'll have is
pkj dk
e j hat or equivalently
what we'll have is e i j
if you're going to consider this
kronecker delta with this v k
then we'll have t i j p i
and this e j is present and you note
that in this particular representation
because the j is the free index here so
you have the presence of this explicit
univected
with the ej and here also it is the j
which is the free here
and which is uh which is consistently
present here
with the ej hat okay and uh if you just
quickly look back
what we had obtained earlier so this tkj
vk
or the t i j v i that is equivalent to
this
p transpose dotted with v okay so
everything is nice and consistent
uh now the question comes we have been
uh
doing various various manipulations with
the
second order tensor and the vector what
about we consider two second order
tenses
okay so suppose we have this particular
combination
so a
contracted with b so
no problem we can write it like a ij
e i diatic product j
this entire thing dotted with
b a l completely different indices
used for the b e k
diatic product l
so when we are writing this in this kind
of an explicit fashion
uh we just take care that each of the
individual tenses are written with
completely separate indices
okay so here also we did the same thing
for the t we used i
n j for v we use the k and then whatever
had to take this took place in a very
algorithmic fashion
and our and our belief is that the same
kind of
nice algorithmic simplifications will
take place here also
okay so here you see
we have first of all a i j and the b k l
coming to one side
and we have these kinds of things
present here
now uh
you see that the real operation the real
contraction operates
operation is through the presence of
this particular combination here the ej
dotted with k
and that result we know is the
moniker delta with the j k
so we'll write that here delta
j k and whatever is remaining here
we'll just write it like this
okay now you see
the way that this term is written here
there is absolutely no problem
okay because whenever we are not writing
anything in between
two two entities like that it basically
by default
means that there is a dyadic product
okay
but in if you really want to make it
very very explicit
you can put the dynamic product symbol
here okay there is no problem
okay and you will see that at the end it
will be uh it will come out as very
consistent okay so what we can do here
so just like before we can consider the
del
the kronecker delta with this term in
which case this j will become a k
or equivalently what we can do is we can
consider the kronecker delta with this
one
in which case the k will become this j
so first of all we do this thing
a i a e
kl e i
id product with el or equivalently
we have a i j
b so this k gets replaced by the j
this is b j l
e i d product with
l and you see in
this term or in this term both of them
being equivalent
what we have is that this i and this l
they are the free indices so had we
written this
in a pure index notation then this i and
this
l being the free indices would have
indicated by themselves
that this particular entity is a second
order tensor
and this k is just a repeated order
dummy index it does not contribute to
the
order of the tensor and very
consistently in this particular
component wise notation
we see that the presence of this e i
direct product with l
represents that this is indeed a tensor
of order 2. similarly in this case
the j here is the repeated index it does
not contribute to the order of the
tensor
the free index i and the free index l
they are contributing to the
tensor of order 2 and that is very much
consistent with the presence of the i
and the presence of the l here okay so
now you see a second order tensor a
dotted with another second order tensor
or contracted
with another second order tensor it is
giving us a tensor
of order two now here
there is a single dot present
which which explicitly means
that this is what we have here is a
single contraction as opposed to this we
could
also have a double contraction double
contraction means
so here ultimately what is happening is
that
so this was initially a i j and this was
b k l
the what we are basically doing is that
we are setting the j equal to k
you see whatever is happening here this
j is becoming equal to k
so ultimately we end up with a i k b k l
or
aij bj okay so ultimately the the heart
of the matter is that
we are setting j is equal to k now had
it had this been a double contraction
then another index also would have been
set equal
okay so in that case the i would have
been set equal to
l uh and uh
you would have ended up with a tensor of
uh of ordered zero okay so uh i think in
one of your
problems in the problem sheet of this
chapter uh you have a problem like this
okay now alternatively suppose we
want to get we want to find out what is
the result of a transpose dotted with
b or contracted with b we can quickly do
that
uh as in
just to have our ideas uh clear
so a transpose
b contracted with b so just like before
we will write the a i j just like that
but because we have the transpose here
we'll write the e j iodine product with
e
i instead of the e i daddy product with
j
and this entire thing will be dotted
with
the d k l e k
at static product with e l
so now as we have always done
so a i j b k l will come to one side
we'll write all these unit vectors in
sequence as they appear
it's a very very algorithmic uh system
so
uh it's it's very easy to deduce the
final expressions
in this form so we have a i j
t k l and
this e i dotted with k that is going to
give us
a delta i k and whatever we have
remaining we can just write it like that
e j and the e l and just to make things
very clear we'll put this
direct product here so finally what
we'll have
is either by considering this delta iq
with the aij in which case we'll have
a a j b
a l uh
e j hat direct product with e l
or we can take the chronicle delta
we can consider the konica delta with
this bkl in which case
we'll have a i j b
and in this case you note that the k
gets replaced by the i
so we have the b
iron
and finally this thing
and just as before you first of all note
that the free indices present here the j
and
l they appear in this unit vectors the e
j and the e l
here also the j and l are appearing here
the j l and l
are appearing here and the positions of
the dummy indices
in the here in the first position here
in the in the first
position with the second one here also
the repeated index of the dummy index
are present in this first positions
okay so when you have a transpose b you
end up with a k j
b k l or a i j b i l as opposed
to the previous case when we did not
have any transpose we ended up with
a i k b k l or a i j b j l
so without the use of this systematic
notation it
sometimes becomes very confusing to
write the equivalent
index notations from this compact
notation
so there can be two other combinations
where you have a dotted with
b transpose and then you can also have a
transpose dotted with b transfers
but i'm not going to go through all
those things you can try them out on
your
own all right so
i think i'll close this part of the
discussion here
and in the in the next part of the
lecture we are going to continue
uh with uh with with another
topic within the chapter of mathematical
preliminaries
uh and that is going to be really really
useful to us
uh as far as the understanding of the
tenses
is concerned all right thank you very
much